one of the things that andrew addresses  in his final message is the fact that  people have cut up clips and manipulated  these clips in order to portray a  completely different narrative why are  they doing this because people literally  are unable to take personal  responsibility it's so easy to rely on  somebody else like i said snowflake  generation they hate the idea that he is  empowering people to take personal  responsibility because personal  responsibility is hard but once you know  how to take personal responsibility  you've been practicing it and you master  it your life becomes so much more  exquisite and andrew is a perfect  example of that